conclusions de ce rapport,
mais les progrès sont lents.
Christian Noël.
(musique autochtone)
- Solidarité et désarroi.
Une douleur inconsolable pour
une tragédie que plusi
estimaient évitable
Rebecca Contois, Doris Trout
et Tessa
autochtones assassinées en
dix s,s,s, à Winnipeg.
Un triste rappel que la violence
en
La tante d'une des victimes
ininine à contenir sa frustrati,
et elle l'a exprimée directement
aux ministres du gouvernement
Trudeau.
"Le manque d'action dugouvernemt
inacceptable, déplore-,,,,
surtout qu'il avait promis de
mettre e
à l'action de la Commission."
Ottawananananaît que les choses
avancent à pas de tortue.
MA
Relations Couronne-Autochtones
u'u'u'u'on sait depuis
le rapport, c'est que
se faire à l'emporte-pièce.CCCÇe
façon systémique.
milliards de dollars pour
l'hébergement, les refuges et
la santé des femmes autochtones.
incapable de démontrer si ses
efforts ont portés fruits, et si
le nombre de meutres a diminué.
mis à jour.
DAVID LAMETTI, ministre fédéral
de la Justice
fait qu'on a jamais recueilli
les doununununune façon basée
sur les distinctions.
LYNNE GROULX, dg Association
- C'est un manque de priorités
po, , , , , un manque de
poussée.
- L'Association canadienne de
la création d'un poste de chien
de gmmmmmmmmmme le recommandait
la Commission, pour forcer
Ottawa à rester vigilant.
n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-n-ne
ce soit de l'extérieur desonono,
ils ne sont pas capable de se
juger eux-mêmes dans ce dossierr
le gouvernement Trudeau pour
la création d'un poste
d'ombudsman dedededededes
Autochtones. Le gouvernement
admet qu'il n'a pas d'excuses
pour son b b b b b b b b b b b e
consolation pour les familles
de......
Ici Christian Noel,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw